we've got a leading international
economist with us now bent Naruto who
has his own consultancy thanks for
coming in right first of all what sort
of businesses business people and
figures do you deal with on a daily
basis we are 50 highly specialized
banking consultants who consult banks
regional banks central banks or
regulatory offices in optimizing all
topics around banking processing
people's business integrating
innovations and so on and integrating
innovation what do you tell them about
online banking what's your advice online
banking will be a big chance for also
the traditional banks to get in touch in
contact with the clients a lot of
clients they don't go to the branch
anymore so it's an easy way to come in
touch and to influence your customer
with a new idea for optimizing finances
and and that also includes customers
relying on other customers I believe yes
they rely but it's a bit different if
you are asking your friend where's a
good restaurant or a nice bar it's the
friends advice in a social network can
you trust to all people are they
friendly are they will they try to
influence you to buy something which is
not optimal for your financing so in
other words going to people you know and
you know well you're close to not just
someone behind a counter to get advice
yeah is that going to mean we're going
to say goodbye to the traditional
banking system or banking model no we
get to a new stage of evolution so
traditional banks belong on of these new
technologies and integrate them in their
business model so they will come in
touch with their customers and they will
gain a new transparency for them we go
of the customer behavior but also for
the customer what are other customers
doing what which kind of products they
prefer how do they do so it will be a
learning community of bankers on the one
side customers on the others and friends
what about the skeptics because we
haven't mentioned that the Germans as I
mentioned earlier in the show very
skeptical about online
can get if we look internationally
they're way behind the rest of the world
especially when using a mobile devote
device to make transactions so using a
tablet or using your mobile phone what's
your explanation I think the Germans
they are traditional people over three
generations they were educated by the
grandma in going to a bank to a branch
talking to the people there it's a it's
an education in a personal credibility
so they adopted this behavior and
putting it to the future in new
economies like in China and Asia people
are much more familiar with new
technologies and they have not this long
history of financial education of
traditional behavior but just yes or no
can they trust these new technologies oh
they should not because everybody who
wants to gain money also with financial
supplies and products so also the new
settings will try to gain money with a
client and a client in financial
behavior he should be skeptic and this
would be like a fox mr. Knoll to thank
you very much for your advice thank you
some very foxy advice from you there